los amantes de productos alimenticios de
grandes empresas de occidente no podrán
volver a consumirlos en rusia esto
después de que cuatro compañías
suspendieron sus ventas en ese país como
represalia contra la guerra en ucrania
mcdonald's dijo que a pesar de que
cerrara los 847 restaurantes que tienen
el territorio seguirá pagando los
salarios a sus 62 mil empleados
no me preocupa que mcdonald cierre creo
que salvar vidas es mucho más importante
que comer comidas sabrosas
pero no todos dicen
el tiempo pasará lento y se sentirá muy
largo será un poco difícil vivir sin un
placer tan culposo pero es posible
los clavos
starbucks también anunció que cerrará
temporalmente cientos de tiendas en
rusia
no puedo decir que me arrepienta habrá
un café diferente es triste ver lo que
está pasando en el país pero lo
superaremos creo que tendremos una
alternativa
quizás echaré de menos ese momento en el
que puedes venir aquí y cansado después
de tus clases para sentarte tomar un
café y comer algo rico aunque no sea
sano y descansar un poco
pepsico suspenderá toda la publicidad en
rusia y dejará de vender sus marcas de
bebidas aunque seguirá ofreciendo
productos esenciales como leche y
alimentos para bebés mientras que su
rival coca-cola dijo que suspenderá sus
negocios en territorio ruso
nadie lo quiere deliberadamente pero si
cierran que cierren habrá más
empresarios rusos aquí
de tanto amazon anunció que dejará de
aceptar nuevos clientes en rusia y
ucrania y universo music suspendió todas
sus operaciones en rusia el servicio de
citas online bamboo retirará sus
aplicaciones de las tiendas de rusia y
belarús y se alejó de comprar petróleo a
rusia e informó que cortará los vínculos
con este país por completo